[Music]
welcome aboard TV fans I'm your host and
captain Leon Aguilera and this is ship
worthy the only show devoted to
celebrating the most swoon worthy
couples on TV and today it's time to
sail into the dark and dangerous world
of Shadowhunters because we're talking
all about the powerhouse pairing of
Harry Shum Jr and Matthew daddario as
Magnus Bane and Alec Lightwood aka
Malick to us plus I've gotten exclusive
never-before-seen interview with Harry
Shum Jr spilling behind-the-scenes malik
secrets so that's going to be the tease
so what happens when a talented
Shadowhunter falls in love with a
prominent downworlder that's what so
let's take a look back at how this
romance first sailed onto our screens in
Anchors Away now Magnus may be a
high-powered and immortal warlock with
hundreds of years of life experience but
when he first caught sight of Cupid I
mean Alec everything changed with just
three later in episode 4 the two fellas
officially met
and I squeal with delight when Alec
became adorably tongue-tied
should really probably good right we
should join the party and then I don't
know about you but I lost my breath and
my heart was beating just a little bit
faster during Magnus's epic monologue to
Alec about why they should embrace their
forbidden romance I know you feel what I
feel Alec it happened just as Alec was
about to bind himself forever to Lydia
Magnus showed up and the rest well the
rest was TV history
[Music]
talk about a truly mesmerizing first
kiss and with that milestone moment
Malick became official as in officially
one of the hottest couples on TV which
leads us into naughty or nice now in
this segment I've hand-picked some of my
all-time favorite Malick scenes and
divided them into two categories
nice which is filled with all those
subtly sweet moments that make us all
flush and naughty which shines the
spotlight on those truly steamy
Shadowhunters scenes first up let's
focus on some nice Mallik moments while
Magnus was open about his attraction to
Alec from the very beginning some of the
sweetest early moments came as the
Shadowhunter adorably stumbled over his
feelings for the high warlock Alyssa
magnesite I wish I I just I don't know
what I understand and my shipper heart
swooned when Magnus did everything he
could think of to bring Alec back to
life including trying out true love's
kiss of course no nice list would be
complete without the couples at first I
love yous which came after Alec feared
the worst when the pair were separated
on a mission I love you I love you too
and as for those naughty moments my
favorite naughty scene between these two
will always be their first time together
when they were fumbling through the
doorway and clearly just enjoying the
moment my feels were overwhelmed and
then of course in the morning after seen
with their pillow talk cuddles it's all
just too cute but are you ready for even
more Malik goodness yeah me too so take
a look at what Harry Shum Jr had to tell
me about why Magnus and Alec mix such a
magical couple fans have such a
passionate reaction to Malick why do you
think that that's a good couple that's
so good together
well I mean you have a magical warlock
and then you have like demon hunter come
together and you get to see a softer
side of them they're not just killing
demons or saving the world they are in a
relationship that is very meaningful and
it's in the beginning and they're
learning so much from each other so I
think it's one of the beginning stages
that a lot of people love watching fans
have loved the fact that Alec kind of
awoken something in Magnus for almost a
century
I've closed myself off to feeling
anything for anyone
you can look something like what is that
bed for you to be able to bring that
character and this couple it alive I
think anyone who's who's ever been in a
relationship or maybe haven't felt that
thing you know that thing that you fight
to the death for and I think when you
see this couple especially with Magnus
he unlocked something in him and he
wants to be able to almost he would die
for him and in a way so I mean when you
see that whether it be what we want to
call it soulmate or you want to call
them a couple that you you or yourself
would die for for them to still be
together I think the fans really react
to that
to make you back you hear me why
wouldn't I look what I have waiting for
me overall there are many many reasons
why I think that Malak are amazing
together Magnus had closed off his heart
for more than a century but then Alec
taught him to love again and Magnus also
helped Alex through his journey of
self-discovery and acceptance while
becoming a more happy and confident
person they're apathetic they're honest
they're loyal to each other and overall
their love is pure plus it's pretty rare
to see a same-sex couple on TV that is
so strongly celebrated and treated with
so much respect both on and off screen
so there I love you Malick there you
have it guys that does it for this first
Malak episode of ship worthy but don't
you worry as I continue to interview
Harry Shum Jr and Matthew daddario we'll
be back with follow-up episodes about
Malick and where their relationship with
a family - next so get excited now if
you had fun sailing with me please give
this video a like and then hit subscribe
to e t--'s youtube channel then drop
anchor in the comments below and tell me
why you love malli as a couple oh and
what were your all-time favorite naughty
or nice moments tell me in the comments
right now plus if you strongly shift any
other TV couples I want to know about it
comment or tweet me with your
nominations of who you think I should
feature on future episodes of ship
worthy and why you love them thanks for
watching ship worthy and until next time
bon voyage TV lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]